Germany's foreign minister says that
turkey must comply with the terms of the
2016 migration deal that calls for it to
stop migrants from crossing from its
territory into the EU
this comes after Turkey deployed special
forces to block the return of any
migrants who illegally entered the EU
Greek police have been forcing such
migrants back into Turkey after they
break through the country's border
defenses faces of despair thousands of
refugees have gathered on the border the
focus on the Turkish town of Edina many
are forced to camp out in the open some
of these people have been displaced by
the long-running conflict in Syria in
Europe you can work there are jobs you
get a decent salary the kids can go to
school you can lead a normal human life
that's all I want I made it to the Greek
side then they took my phone my money
they took my clothes off they beat me
and sent me back to Turkey this is just
wrong we want to be able to breathe
freely when I was 12 years old I had to
leave school my parents were killed in
the war others have come from
Afghanistan and Pakistan they find
shelter where they can dozens crammed
into this abandoned bus station Turkey's
president has carried out his threat to
open the border to Europe if NATO did
not back his military operation in
northern Syria the Red Crescent and Red
Cross are helping out where they can on
the ground handing out food and water
and providing basic shelter we are ready
to do whatever is needed to restore
dignity
what we are missing in this moment is
the dignity for the human beings that
are in the middle of this political game
we are ready to do whatever is necessary
to provide dignity to those that are
stuck with this moment in the
nomenclature Ankara for its part is
determined that those who do make it
across to Greece will not be sent back
into Turkish territory
Special Forces officers are being
deployed to the river on the border
fully equipped to prevent people being
pushed back Greece is equally determined
to prevent a flood of new arrivals the
authorities say some 35,000 migrants
have tried to cross illegally into Greek
territory in the past week Athens
insists those who reach its soil will be
deported let's get the very latest now
at EWS Yulia Han she joins us now from
the Turkish side of that border good day
to you Leah can you fill us in what's
the situation at the border where you
are this morning well the situation here
appears to remain that tense now as
journalists we're not allowed to get
anywhere near the border or this main
border crossing here between Turkey and
Greece anymore police are stopping us
right here about two kilometres away but
a little earlier we managed to get a
little closer with our car because we
were again before we were again stopped
by the gendarme ahir and we managed to
talk to some migrants and refugees who
told us that tear gas had been fired
again we could also smell the tear gas
and it's right now not entirely clear if
this was just being fired from the Greek
side towards Turkey there are also
reports that teargas have been fired
from the Turkish side it's not entirely
clear what role Turkish military there
is playing there are some reports saying
that or suggesting that the soldiers
they are kind of encouraging the
refugees or migrants maybe to use
violence in order to demamp
to Europa the people we talk to also
told us that although they have some
access to food and drinks the
temperatures here are particularly
difficult they have to sleep on you know
plastic covers during the night and they
also told us there are still thousands
waiting there waiting to cross into the
European Union but as I said it's very
difficult to get an independent
understanding of the situation but from
what we understand it remains tense okay
it's tense and also we've been reporting
this morning on groups of refugees
who've been moved around at the border
area Yaya is there any idea as to why
these groups of refugees have been moved
on
and where they've gone to I can tell you
about I can tell you about one group
we've been filming with them last
evening they had kind of build up a
makeshift camp in the town of dilma very
near to where we are right now about 200
people many families with small children
people from Syria Afghanistan Pakistan
these people told us we are determined
to stay we will wait for Greece to open
the borders and when we arrived at the
same location earlier today again it was
suddenly emptied all the people had been
moved somewhere else that's our
understanding because I talked to one
police officer who told me is we took
the people and buses to this area to
this main border crossing so it appears
Turkish authorities are somehow
facilitating people's move and directing
what's going on here at the border and
just a few moons ago Yulia we looked at
what what looked like a a blacked-out
bus moving just behind you there
at the border where there's a lot of
activity behind you this morning Yulia
hon thanks so much for being with us for
now
well the EU is concerned that the
fighting in Syria will create new flows
of refugees heading for Europe and EU
foreign ministers are meeting in the
Croatian capital Zagreb today to discuss
those developments you foreign affairs
chief joseph morales backing a dutch
plan for a buffer zone to stop attacks
on civilians in rebel-held Inlet
province but he says the bloc has no
power to enforce the measure the German
Foreign Minister Heiko Maas is also
supporting security guarantees for
civilians in the region Greece's foreign
minister is expected to press his
counterparts were there help in coping
with the latest arrival of migrants at
the Greek border our EU correspondent
Erik Mathis is following that meeting of
foreign ministers for us good morning to
you Georg um what's the EU prepared to
do to help Greece cope with another
potential migrant crisis unfolding at
this hour on its border
apart from financial aid to help with
the refugees that are already in the
country brine there is now order also a
force of 100 border officers from
frontex the eves Border Agency on their
way to Greece supposed to arrive next
week in order to guard the potentially
difficult parts where Greece borders
turkey with boats but also also with
personnel on the ground so support for
Greece but what is really essential here
is the message from foreign ministers in
Zagreb that they do a support that
turkey that Greece really offends off
illegal migrants from crossing that it
is a stronghold on the external borders
of the EU in Gori we're going to take a
look right now at a root cause of this
crisis the deteriorating situation in
Syria fighting in illah province has
created for six hours talks continued
then air dhawan and Putin stepped out in
front of the cameras to announce a
security corridor joint patrols
and above all a ceasefire saut souffl
suffers tonight at 12 a.m.
that is midnight between the 5th and 6th
of March the ceasefire will take effect
and all steps will be taken to abide by
it the talks began at midday there was
little left of the friendly rapport that
was apparent only days before air Dejuan
and Putin looked tense this situation is
complicated Russia and Turkey are at
loggerheads in the Syrian province of
Idlib their Syrian leader Assad's troops
are fighting rebels with support from
Russia
the rebels are supported by Turkish
troops but air dhawan and Putin say they
are committed to de-escalation we hope
this agreement will lay a foundation for
the suspension of fighting enid lib we
hope to end the suffering of civilians
there and to avoid a greater
humanitarian crisis you don't know when
they should in you
it was the outcome of hours long
difficult negotiations now the ceasefire
will face its big test if and how long
it can hold Georg this looks like a key
ceasefire how important to you foreign
ministers meeting there in Zagreb think
the ceasefire is in helping reduce the
flow of migrants heading towards the EU
external border all foreign ministers I
hear heard here on the second day of
their meeting welcomed the idea and made
however clear that is of course
necessary that this is a sustainable a
ceasefire and they have to look at the
details how it actually works out
throughout the course of of the week and
to what extent it will then deliver an
easing of the humanitarian suffering you
see in Syria and that is why there's
also financial aid extra a hundred
seventy million now on the table to aid
people in Syria 60 million directly in
the region of eat lip and the Dutch
Foreign Minister arrived here this
morning saying at the No
so I the buffer zone is a good idea he
likes the ceasefire but it will also
take a no-fly zone now a number of
foreign ministers liked that idea - but
of course it is something that have to
be has to be channeled via the United
Nations you need a resolution for that
and for that you need Russia on board
and so it's a complicated scenario
whether you really asked and no other
say but put some moral pressure on the
table or some ideas
I like that no-fly zone turkey has
already been very specific it says it
wants the EU to offer it more political
support more financial support is it
likely to get those things a German
Foreign Minister agamous here in Zagreb
ruled out that there will be any direct
payment to Turkey it's a bit unclear
whether a Turkish aid organizations
within the deal that the EU has made in
order to help turkey deal with some four
million refugees that are in the country
so billions have been flowing from
Brussels to Turkey whether more money
will come that way but what is clear is
that all foreign ministers made clear
there will be no blackmail there will be
no using of refugees as bargaining chips
in order to force Europe to spend more
money some very clear signals from
Zagreb gehrig thanks so much for that